from the layman to the person that's
from again afghanistan for the
general public who just want to know
about what's going on in
afghanistan so we have someone who's an
entrepreneur a humanitarian someone
who's heavily involved in afghanistan
who has family in afghanistan
and knows the situation on the ground
some of the history of it so we're going
to get to covering many of these
important aspects so you like me the
layman can get more well-grounded and
know what's really going on in
afghanistan with my next guest coming up
ramit allah the rules here on the dean
show
assalamu alaikum peace be with you how
you doing my brother
peace be with you how are you brother
alhamdulillah
it's uh nice to have you on the program
i've watched this show
for all my life you know the first time
you started dawa i was very young
in malaysia and watching you that
inspiration masha'allah until now i
wanted to meet you in malaysia but uh
you don't
i think subur told me they don't like to
travel a lot
so martial law we are meeting here now
masha'allah what are you talking about
when you're young look at you you're
still young
[Laughter]
i was young meaning that when i was 18
19 yeah you don't look much older than
that
i know i'm 28 so yeah
yeah masha allah alhamdulillah it's very
nice to meet you my brother thank you
allah bless you
uh tell us so now again begin a lot of
requests many of us are ignorant
we get fed a lot about spoon fed to us
from the media
and most people are hip on you know if
they've kind of you know that uh red
pill blue pills you know they call it
you know some people get awoken to a lot
of the you know media lies and deception
so people are coming to us and they want
to know what's really going on in
afghanistan why don't we
start off with the early beginnings you
know some of the history and then we'll
take it from there how's that
i mean it should be a
we will try to answer the question that
uh uh most people wanted to know
so afghanistan for those people who
don't know afghanistan at all i will
give you a brief um history
afghanistan is a country
all our life the country have been in
conflict
if you know it even from thousand years
it's been in conflict either internally
or externally external reasons there
were invasions from outside
because of geographical location because
of the heart of the asia you have close
contact with russia you have close
contact with china and same goes to
pakistan the
sea and so on and so forth
but we will go only to the 90s in soviet
union their invasion uh
to just to you know give them a brief
history
so actually afghanistan was invaded for
multiple reasons
why the britisher came in when they were
in india they were afraid that soviet
union will come to afghanistan and then
attack them in india so they attack
afghanistan at once and they were there
they couldn't get hold of it and then
the soviets they wanted to of course
rule the world they did not only invaded
afghanistan they were happening
everywhere but they entered afghanistan
and i believe in 1978 they were there
for 10 years and
1987 or 1989
they left and ultimately soviet union
were collapsed in february 1991 and then
the russian federation was born
so the soviet when they were there
actually to be honest if i were to
compare the afghan men i would compare
the soviets were much better than
americans
reasons i will tell you number one
their values were clear why they came
there what they wanted to do and they
had future plans in afghanistan
they built infrastructure roads which
exist until today they build tunnels
from jalabad to lakman and other
provinces like kabul and those tunnels
even exist today
the work they have done was actually
long lasting work it wasn't a temporary
work unlike americans they built
everything with
piece of wood
plastic and so the moment they leave
they can just you know blast it away and
they did not come with the intention to
help the country they came with their
own intention which we'll discuss
so i mean soviet left and mujahideen
which were heavily funded by the
americans which is clear i mean
everybody know about that so wait wait
for the people that don't know
for the people that don't know let's uh
let's stop at that point so what do you
just repeat rewind you just said that
they were the taliban at that time they
were heavily funded they were pretty
much
back
not the television
and
they were so they were
pretty much
um
allies to who
to america to america so this is
well-known this is documented this is
this is well known and they didn't know
that i mean ordinary people didn't know
that but the leader they didn't know
i would tell you my father was
in those groups and you know he he was a
fighter he fought against the russian
he's been hit two time by the bullets
even his one leg is shot
because
these people were fighting on the ground
they didn't know that the money was
coming through america so they were
pretty much by americans they were
considered heroes yes
so the americans at that time it's
interesting how things change now so at
that time uh we were prompting the
muhajin helping them and considering
them heroes
yes because they were achieving american
interest
wow there were two interests for example
for afghan it was an invasion it was
fight between islam and kufur and
american seed we're seeing it okay this
is a fight against the soviet why we are
fighting in ukraine other part of the
world why not we fund the mujahideen uh
we don't have collateral damage we do we
don't give our soldiers so let them
fight so the mujahideen didn't know the
money is coming from america
what they used to do they used to
challenge the money to saudi arabia and
saw these sheikhs would go to
afghanistan and give the money in form
of donation
but it wasn't actually donation from
saudi because it could not carry a war
by donation
and the money would come to pakistan and
pakistan would form the militant group
the mujahideen were freedom fighters and
then send them to different part of
afghanistan and they would [ __ ] the
russians ultimately the russian feder
the soviet union
so in those time my father was sharing a
story they didn't know the money would
come
on donkeys and horses from pakistan for
example from peshawar there were no
proper roads so my father he was hearing
one story that one day they gave us like
a lot of courses
and we didn't know what it is
so on the way one horse he fell down and
then the bags were open and the finals
were all dollars
and they didn't know what dollar is you
know currency
they didn't know what dollar is so they
packed the money and brought it back to
their leaders
so in short it's a well documented
everybody knows about that even the so
the mujahideen leaders
they came to washington they met and
they translated the translator was
actually uh the recent guy who fixed the
deal between america and taliban so this
is i mean
well documented story we don't have to
go to details yeah that the mujahideen
were funded by the americans because
they were sharing the same interest
that's number one and this will this
will this we will talk about this as
well what russians did
with warring against americans so your
family your family is currently in it
you have found you're you were you born
in afghanistan yeah it was one that was
so you're uh born there you have history
there obviously your family's there
you're heavily involved there with
business humanitarian projects is that
right
that's true true yes i my family is
there my father is alhamdulillah still
alive
i have
businesses in afghanistan we have number
of schools we have an organization a
non-profit organization working on the
ground we have projects all over
afghanistan
i think we have more than 32 projects we
have a dawah and research center in
afghanistan answering people questions
about islam so and i've met a lot of
people in afghanistan if it's from the
previous government if you're
the governors the ministers sit with
them talk with them and try to get some
permission for the work and we will
discuss
inshallah
the corruption inside the government so
on and so forth i just want to come to
history of taliban yeah so we we've got
to have you call it the proper term
afghani someone from afghanistan is an
afghani
he's african actually afghani would be
the currency i'm also confusing this you
know okay the afghan would have brought
his currency actually so how do you call
someone like who's from there so from
someone from america american what
he's afghan afghan so you're an afghan
someone who knows the history well we
got someone an expert from this area
who's also got a lot of underground
experience working with many of these
different organizations trying to better
the society there now for many of us we
get to see the images of what looks like
a country blown back into the stone age
so a lot of times we get these attacks
from much of the hate machine propaganda
like oh you muslims you muslims what
have you developed you know you guys are
backwards just look at afghanistan iraq
but now let's take it to the second
phase
why did now things turn and the change
happened from being supporting
and now to creating this
now oh they oppress women oh we got to
come
and we have to save them and et cetera
et cetera and the tides everything's
pretty much changed and the images we
just have been seeing it just war-torn
just uh blown back into the stone age
that's true that i mean the point is if
the western powers they would leave
these countries alone
and they would not send them their
weapons and support
one time one party sometimes support
both parties so they can fight and they
can use their weapons and their guns and
they make profit out of it if they don't
do that i think every country will
develop and they i mean look at america
look at their history i mean
they also had the same age it doesn't
mean that no country can develop and
there's a problem in it for example look
at malaysia look at uae um they had in
past 50 years what they have done
because they were left alone nobody
used them for their own agendas and
nobody funded them nobody created group
amongst them and make them fight each
other so i will come to the brief
history
post 911 uh
when mujahideen of course
basically they
they kick out soviet union or
afghanistan and they had several war
because of
the foreign influence americans were
supporting different groups inside the
mujahideen and of course you know other
countries supporting different groups
and then the formation of taliban
happened in 1994 and the first military
action they took and they took the
government i mean the entire afghanistan
in 1996.
when they took the afghanistan the cia
was already present afghanistan people
think it's
they came to afghanistan 9 11 no that's
completely a false claim
they were in afghanistan in northern
area afghanistan the ca like black
cooper there's a book director is
written by steve cool and they were
already president of honest i'm planning
how to take over
afghanistan 9 11 was just a
you can say a blame you know of a reason
for them to open the doors to enter
afghanistan of course if for example
there was nobody from one sun involved
the plane did not departure from
afghanistan no citizen even osama bin
laden was in afghanistan you have a lot
of other ways to pressure a country to
give up a human being you can block
money bank transfer you can actually
sanction them financial sanctions you
can sanction through medicine humanity
like you can stop even sending them
basic items like food and so on and so
forth but they do not use any of those
pressures they right away invaded and by
the way osama bin laden when he was
when he died i mean there there's a
different claim if he died natural death
or you were killed by americans i was in
pakistan very close to iptop
when they attacked him and nobody knew
in that area so the point is the people
who claim
that afghanistan's stone age because of
the muslims and look you guys are all
muslim look at your country it's not
because of this is because of you you
understand
you don't leave us alone and if you
change your foreign policies trust me we
will make things better
so we hear this term now never forget 9
11 and like you said this was used as a
pretext to go ahead and invade these
different countries now you have a lot
of let me just make a disclaimer here
obviously islam muslims we go
making this very lucidly clear that
islam has nothing to do with killing
innocent men women and children
you know
this is something that's very clear in
the quran in islam
so but we have
many americans who now are coming out
you have i think 4 000 almost 4 000
architects and engineers and others who
are educating the people that hold on
you know this was something of you know
uh that this wasn't what they're
painting it out to be you know like that
building seven they did an independent
study uh i believe it was uh in arkansas
i'm not sure exactly where but they said
there was no way that this building 7 or
these buildings could just come down by
fire
and we've discussed this before on the
program so it's interesting this this is
how everything this was a catalyst that
kicked everything off but now you have
so many people who are demanding a new
investigation et cetera et cetera that's
not a topic of the show but it's linked
back because of this
islam was now under attack muslims under
attack countries invaded
under this pretext
so
what do you have to say about that
uh actually there are two types of
people for example living in america
there are innocent civilians
who are
who have been
their money their tax money and their
trust
everything will be misused by the
politicians and people in power who are
actually
looking for economical reasons there is
no other missions rather than economical
reasons
to invade countries and go and wage war
on them and label them some with the
terrorists and some with the different
labels then
and i'm sorry for people who are
actually being misled by their lies
so
yesterday the people who were fight of
uh fighting the russians they were
heroes and they were freedom fighters
and today people are fighting american
invasion they're terrorists so you can
see the difference
and as i said earlier
they have bombarded them with lies and i
remember my mother-in-law was sharing
she was in america at that time in 9 11
the whole tv channels that the entire
media outlets were only talking about
afghanistan
and they were discussing the stories and
then they were sharing unfortunately
some people also do that i'm not denying
that that these countries have no
problems kind of like afghanistan no we
do have thousands of problems just like
the western countries we have different
problems than u.s they were regularly
sharing that woman was
being lashed by a man
yes i understand that there is a problem
with that but
to discuss those problems the only
solutions to invade them no that's not
the solution for example in germany the
country that i'm living right now
you have domestic violence every hour
against a woman like we will speak for
hours and imagine every other 40 000
women reporting every year and
everything is domestic violence against
women so now americans should invade
germany to fix this problem
i mean
if they look at their own problems like
single motherhood the issue of his hiv
cases this is the issue of homelessness
but they don't talk about those problems
when they have domestic problem they try
to portray other countries oh there's a
problem let's be heroes and let's invite
them and let's feed them democracy so
they can live better life and when they
go there they literally kill people and
out of that killing they make profit and
we can go in the details of how much
americans actually made from afghanistan
by going to war and i'm seeing every
media outlet is keep on saying that we
have spent trillions of dollars
and we will discuss that too that's a
good point because that's something here
that's kind of hush hush you don't see
much media coverage of the sex trade
it's such a big industry here in the u.s
and the pedophile rings and the
pornography incest i mean through the
roof
you know an epidemic you know of
kids being molested and sex trade and
all these things that are just kind of
not talked about by the media but
they're happening and then the hypocrisy
pointing fingers at you know other
places uh for women's rights but you
know obviously we should be for human
rights all over the place but then to go
ahead and i think uh people see through
this uh the pretext that's used to go
ahead and now
uh go ahead and plunder
and go ahead and talk to us about yeah
what you just said like how much you
know the
the we're told that in afghanistan you
have um what is it uh lithium you have
the trillion dollars of minerals all of
these things the poppy seeds you know
big business you know
you know iraq it was oil here what's the
interest because you have other
countries that now you can go ahead and
invade that you know people are you know
oppressing women or doing certain things
which again has nothing to do with islam
uh but what kind of money is is
afghanistan sitting on that now would
entice others to come in and try to
plunder from it and was this actually
happened was this proven to happen
yes okay
let's look at it in two ways number one
people need to understand
the american government is printing
money and they can bring money out of
thick air
so for them to say that we spend
trillions of dollars it's not like they
took a cash out of their own banks and
trigger to afghanistan and spend it on
people no they just printed papers and
brought it to people
and why how they are benefiting if
anybody would understand how the
currency system work
if there is a demand for a currency and
you print your currency in spending
you create a demand that's how you can
value your currency you can print more
money for example
if there was no afghanistan war and they
would print three or two trillion
dollars
then the value of dollar will be lower
than a lot of currencies because the
demand is not there in the market but
they printed more money
so if they invade a country and they
make everything in dollar in that
country that mean they created a demand
in that country so therefore the
american dollar become more stronger and
therefore they made a profit out of it
for example i will tell you
when saudi arabia they stopped actually
you know
when the standard of gold after world
war ii was by nixon president xl it was
you know
uh they chose not to use standard of
gold anymore in the currency and
countries like germany and france they
were demanding because the american give
them loan and then they took back they
said okay you know what if you i give
you a loan for example i think a 12
billion dollar and if you give me this
money back i can give you gold in return
so when they were demanding their own
money okay take back your currency the
paper money and give me the gold now and
they say you know what we don't have
that much gold
so
there was no demand for american dollar
why should i keep american dollar
because it's a paper so they talked to
saudi arabia and saudi arabia decided to
sell their oil only with dollars
and their demand was created so all the
countries needed dollars in order to buy
the oil
so that's how the demand of the currency
is created now coming back to
afghanistan
when american invaded afghanistan they
brought their own defense contractors
everybody was brought from america
companies like i can list a lot of
companies
even the military contracts like
blackwater
the the the people on the ground
fighting were not actual american army
they were sub-contractors a private
company were fighting in afghanistan and
they were given complete immunity that
even if you kill 10 000 children
no quote will even appeal against you
yeah we heard it there's a lot of
there's different documentaries like
dirty wars and whatnot
that the atrocities that many of these
contractor groups they were you know
raping women
they were doing so many killing innocent
people yeah talk about that
i will come to that so just want to talk
about this their profit how much they
made in afghanistan
so when they came to afghanistan with
their money they also brought people and
they paid them highest amount of salary
because that money was printed named
afghanistan anyway so if you're coming
as a computer scientist you were given
salary forty thousand a month salary
fifty thousand that much so imagine i
would talk about only one other company
that's that the
and
do you know the pepsi coca-cola bottle
how much was calculated for american
army 14
40
the pricing were
huge
washing a piece of clothes you know this
piece of clothes would cost american
army 100
and you can do it behind the base with
10 cent so that's how they channel back
the money to america and they used the
label
that this money was spent in afghanistan
no the money was not spent in
afghanistan it was channeled back to
america so i will tell you some of the
companies how much they made out of this
afghanistan and even the some of the
iraq like hollister the kb uh k
bureau logistic company they had 39.39.5
billion dollar in contract
can you believe that thirty nine point
five
thirty nine point five billion almost
forty billion huh
yes that that's what their contract for
example out of this time like the ten
years or the twenty years
the ceo i think i remember his name they
see woo made 30 35.9 million dollar only
their ceo can you imagine that so the
money was not giving to afghan by the
way
and again the second company which is
the titan teeth titan basically made
again
billions of dollars out of this and they
see who made
47.2 billion million dollar only in 2004
casey jb london was a ceo who made
22.9 million dollar from the war in
afghanistan didn't they have like the
the former vice president and other
politicians here they had also invested
in interest in many of the uh weapons
manufacturing companies yes yes they
have invested
so when people said you spent 2.9
trillion dollar in afghanistan that's a
complete lie
i will tell you i have traveled all over
afghanistan we do not have a single
hospital
for people to do their heart surgeries
kidney surgeries you don't have any of
the hospital we don't have a school a
single school with lcd screen there
thousands of students are studying on
the stones actually where the money
don't have
the money was not spended in the first
place
you do not have a single highway in
afghanistan you did not have a single
hospital single school no base was built
by the americans
even the biggest bagram it was all built
by
you know using woods
nothing proper infrastructure look at
the roads
so the money was not spent in
afghanistan they just printed in the
name of afghanistan was channeled back
to america and that's how they made
money from their own they created demand
okay
they created demand and they made
everything in dollar in afghanistan like
even cargo silver dollars everything
with dollars and then they printed and
then they channeled back to america
despite how much they took from the
minerals how much they took from the
land how much they took from other
countries but they also took from the
nato and from the europe from australia
but who benefited the most and doing
research on this matter how much america
actually
benefit from 20 years of war in advance
how much is that around approximately
i think it's more than five uh trillion
dollar
so it was a big racket as they call it
it's a big uh
big racket and a lot of plundering a lot
of people getting rich on the backs of
the afghanistan uh afghan people
yep and they tested their medicine
afghanistan i would tell you if a pharma
industry was trying to cover some sort
of medicine they would send it to
afghanistan for the testing users guinea
pigs
yes they have tested their weapon in
afghanistan if a weapon company would
come in they want to see it actually on
the ground before they sell it to gulf
countries into other countries they
would test that weapon in afghanistan
for example the mother of all bum 100 i
think thousand tons something they
dropped that bomb in afghanistan for
what for the reason of test
to how much damage it can actually make
so it was well documented so they can
sell it on other countries here's let me
tell you just kind of uh what the
feeling on the ground you know usually
the layman
is like okay we have to go over there
this is what they've been
sold that we have to go over there
otherwise they're going to come over
here so those people over there in the
cave
who are just you know without a tv they
don't even really care what's going on
like you gave in a great example of the
the donkey with the money and they
didn't even know about the what's this
so something you know
somehow people have been brainwashed you
know programmed to believe that hold on
those terrorists they don't those
muslims over there in afghanistan iraq
they hate us so much they hate our way
of life that's the main message they
hate our way of life so they came over
here they took down you know the uh they
attacked us
and now we have to go over there so they
don't come here again
what do you what would you say to the
average american anyone who
had this talk with you and they brought
this up to you how would you respond to
that
i think
they should watch some of the youtube
videos the youtubers who have been to
afghanistan their people okay the
youtubers that they follow and they are
subscribed to and see what's the
response to the people
against america and american people
secondly you give them business
opportunities and travel visa everyone
would love to come to america for a few
days and go back to his own country so
if there was a hatred nobody would even
apply for the visa you can see how many
people are applying annually to america
for either business purposes or travel
so and so forth
nobody hates other country why they
should hate and if they hate anyone
there if for example let's assume they
hate non-muslims right why they don't
attack india close by
non-muslim muslims rule india for 800
years why did not kill any everyone
there why they don't attack nearby
country like you know you have
non-muslim in afghanistan we do have six
in afghanistan we have hindus why don't
we attack them
no if you don't attack them why should
we attack you number one that that's a
false propaganda the they're giving them
that they hate our way of life no we
muslims we love our own way of life we
might disagree with you on certain
things but islam does not give us any
legitimacy to hate you or to attack you
for no reason so that's a wrong and
false information they're getting i had
a true story i personally
had a i was on a call with a uh
a person by the name of jason he was in
the marines and he spent some time in
afghanistan so
he wanted some advice
because his story started off with him
going to afghanistan and then having
what they call someone shadow him that's
like an interpreter someone from
afghanistan and he said it left such an
impression on jason
the american
the marine there in afghanistan
that the kindness that he experienced
he'd never experienced his back at home
so that was number one number two the
afghan who was there with him gave him a
copy of the quran so for those that
don't know the not yet muslims the quran
is the verbatim word of god almighty
allah i suggest you read it
so he actually read the quran and what
opened his heart to reading the quran
was the kindness that he experienced
from the afghan people there
and now so much so that he's almost like
you know uh he's like if you ask me he's
he's muslim because he's praying he's
doing everything he's reciting because
to pray you have to recite the shahada
but he hasn't come out formally he's
scared because what his wife now she's
from romania and she's um orthodox
christian and she's he's scared like
what's going to happen the repercussions
of that
he's not going to be able to go with her
to church on sunday he's going to have
to cut out pork you know and et cetera
et cetera she's going to be getting
really worried why aren't you eating the
pork why aren't you coming with me so
that's his dilemma anyways
so many cases of this of people going
down there and experiencing if afghan
and the people of the society for
themselves and seeing through the
propaganda have you experienced this
also where people have thought one way
and then they actually got on a plane
they got down or they connected with
muslims and now their impression totally
changed
that's true actually if you are coming
through your politician do you trust
your politician hundred percent when
it's talking about your internal affairs
if you don't trust them on your internal
effect hundred percent then why do you
trust them on external effects what was
the reason for them to invade and wage
war in vietnam
what was the reason for other countries
was that they hated the way you live
whatsoever what was the reason for
indians what is the reason for example
inside the mexican the cities that were
taken away from the mexicans and their
brutal killings so you don't have reason
they need reason to invade countries and
to profit from it and they use you as a
tool to give them justification do that
if you really want to know about how
muslims uh i mean what the muslim
thinking are or afghan thing in general
you go and simply talk to one human
being that's it
from that you know country or from that
belief and if you find him like violence
and so on and so forth then yes you're
right but i would say 100 that you'll
not find any of them uh intending to
harm you but they would love to help you
as i mentioned youtubers the reason i
mentioned youtubers because they would
trust them they have come to afghanistan
and even their videos for pakistan that
everything is free in pakistan if you
come as a foreigner to a country they
will not even take money from you if you
buy something small or big they will say
you know what you're a guest look at
hospitality
yes there are videos actually you can
see it when you see qatar and oman in
these countries they are muslim too you
don't have the same feeling about them
because they are rich maybe that's the
reason you know rich muslim is a good
muslim poor person is a bad muslim
what's the reason but personally
speaking that you know facebook and
social media everything is there
why don't you talk to somebody instead
of having uh
what happened
usually
for example like muhammad hijab is a
very aggressive human being for example
he is not by the way
and if i
meet one day muhammad hijab and i'll
tell him okay because i was told already
that he's aggressive human being even
though with love and compassion maybe
that's his character he squeezed me a
little bit because he loved me
and because he's very
compassionate
and i would say you know what he's an
aggressive human being because i was
told
there's a i know it's very
difficult to differentiate the
subconscious feeling that we have
against somebody sometimes and it's not
our own feelings like nunchumsky we said
that construction consists that the
choices that we are making are not our
choices actually other people choices
but we think that they're our choices so
if you're making a choice against the
muslim or against any person that your
politician your media is telling you
that they are so maybe you should see to
it is that really your choice or you
were fed through media outlets that
that's your choice and that's how you
should react to it let's go back a
little bit and look at the history after
the russians left the soviet union and
now something that again was happening
on the ground tell us we hear of these
warlords and again differentiating islam
and the actions of human beings who go
away from islam and they end up doing
certain things specifically there was
this nationalism and we know the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him who often says the brother to
jesus moses they all came with the same
message worship one and only one god the
creator of heavens and earth so prophet
muhammad he warned us of this
nationalism he said it stinks you know
it's something rotten to the core
was this happening at that time and
could this have been something that led
to a lot even more evil on the ground
can you talk about this
yes unfortunately as i mentioned earlier
the group were fighting the russians
there were no doubt people independently
fighting and there were some of them
fighting owned by foreign
[Music]
powers like america and some other
countries so when the fighting was over
every one of them wanted to have some
sort of power and authority
somebody wanted to become the prime
minister somebody wanted to have like
the presidency system republican system
some different ideology were there and
that actually escalated to internal
civil war and they were fighting between
each other in islam uh fighting is
prohibited and you know you cannot fight
over power over nationalism as you
mentioned uh rightly and there's a
hadith of the prophet saw allah anybody
who fought for land or tribal reason
he's not one of us even if he died that
you cannot label him whether the majahid
or shaheeds on and so forth so those
were the reasons and with those reasons
of course when there's a civil war a lot
of atrocities happen just like
after the war in germany uh when you
know the russia that americans and
english soldiers they came into germany
they raped i think over 40
yeah i think over 40 000 women and
because there was no control it's a
well-documented history
so a lot of rape took place uh there
were a lot of violence and that's how
taliban group was formed taliban
actually mean uh taliban and by the way
i have to make this clarification that
i'm not sight of anybody i'm not here to
represent taliban or to you know affirm
what they have done they have done
horrible stuff we will discuss on this
live show as well they are not free from
error and we are not saying everything
taliban is doing part of islam or
everything they have done is completely
islamic no they have mistakes and the
things they have done correctly we will
praise them things they have done wrong
we will definitely criticize them and
point out this is what they have done is
wrong
so that that's good
that's a good point let's stop right
there we're trying to get some education
we're not here trying to
promote any political group but
at all costs we will um try to bring the
true message of islam and
differentiating what islam says and
you know from what the for people might
do it's opposite to islam
it's true uh so that's how when there
were civil war and a lot of
you know
problems on the ground so the taliban
there was a rape case of a girl i i only
go to more details because we have other
matters to discuss so the taliban group
was formed and since they were not
affiliated with any other parties and
they did they only wanted to establish
islamic government and they were mostly
students from madrasa so there were
students like maybe from 20 to 30 and 40
very young were young
people their demographic and then they
started to get people's love and
attention and then they formed their own
government in 1996 uh the military there
was some attraction too and they formed
their own government and the government
was very established all over
afghanistan but not in some areas like
northern areas uh they couldn't capture
those areas and uh they were still
fighting with taliban
going on but that was the background of
taliban and taliban were not accepted by
many countries they only were accepted
by i believe iran uae in pakistan
or saudi arabia even american did not
accept them as a government they were
mostly working with northern airlines
which were active at that time so that
that's a that's a background and when
americans invaded afghanistan so what
they do number of mistakes i would say
number one the invasion itself was a
mistake even if you plan to invade a
country you don't have to do it like
that uh blood part that you give to the
country i think
over 300 or 400 000 people died because
of that um
the second mistake they did they brought
people in power were all corrupt
warlords
they were not trusted by anybody on the
ground by civilians and then they
created a different groups and tribalism
like sort of like okay you're target you
have to support your leader your uzbek
have supported your leader they brought
people into parliament who could not
read and write their own names they were
all americans they just you know they
brought by american for example
president karzai
was informed that you have become
president come can you believe that wow
president karzai was in kandahar and a
cia agent and
quarter he informed him that you have
become a president come back to kabul
so then he had to come to kabul and
that's how this is thing all started
so
second mistake american did number one
they invaded afghanistan number two they
chose people to lead the country were
the least
uh
the least
how would i say the least
um choices people by the country
something like the least fit the least
qualified
the least to find the least fit for the
positions
people as a minister they could not read
and write their own name
parliament members
and they were only thing he knew is
killing and and nobody loved them
actually the second thing was when they
killed all the talibans
they did not plan
how
their children would react
how their grandchildren would react
their neighbors and they would utilize
themselves there was no such plan for
them there was no such plan they thought
okay we upgraded of them to over and now
we have everything and they thought we
would buy our people with cash and that
was not true they tried to fled the
country with a lot of cash and
they tried to buy everybody but they
couldn't they were people were fighting
for the dean for their you know for
their raider and for their country they
were freedom fighters and people who
were with them and the government that
they formed was
corrupt to the degree that you don't
have measure and that other problem that
was there actually
they couldn't build infrastructure they
couldn't give proper justice the economy
was fictional there was no actual
economy americans were paying people
salary for 20 years they didn't own any
factories or economic they did not
increase the gdp so they were paying
they they made them heavily dependent on
america so everything they were saying
and americans were so involved that even
a sub governor
if you want to be sub governor you need
to have the approval of americans
they were so involved for example my
father was sub governor inaudible and i
i talked to some of the americans on the
ground the army from blackwater and do
you believe uh brother that they were
actually in prison
these defense contractors they went to
the prisons and told them if you want to
fight in afghanistan we will free you
and you can go and you will get this
much paid
because the guy was
i talked to money there was
there was a since you mentioned that uh
where there also is i remember having a
guest on and he was talking about
uh a woman by the name of afia siddiqui
and they were talking he was talking
about how they had people who were
taking innocent people
and accusing them of terrorism to get
paid the government was paying like 50
000 or some some money it was like a
racket of human beings just to go ahead
and be able to have the pretext to go
ahead and get the funding to continue
this war on terror did you did you hear
about that you know about that
yes it's true because they they took
anybody to just prove that there's
action going on and second thing is
americans themselves funded the violence
of they created their own groups though
i have
firm belief the american created their
own groups to create war so they can say
to the national community there's a war
therefore we're staying you understand
and second thing is our terror my father
was some governor sub current is a big
guy by the way president governor and
sub-governor in the region
and a few times my father asked the
americans because of governor the
government he was in close contact with
americans he asked them why do you drop
weapon to the other parties
they literally drop weapons a night to
different groups and then the my father
was told it was done by mistake
how you do that
like
they were dropping weapon areas to
create conflict so there is a reason for
them to stay in that area and there was
using economical problems i don't think
you're going to hear we're getting the
inside scoop of what was really
happening on the ground
with someone who knows the
day-to-day activity that's going that's
been happening the history and i'm
really thankful that you're sharing this
with us so people can get a better
perspective you're not going to get this
you know on the mainstream channels so
please contin continue on uh i wanted to
ask you so how many innocent people
again
actually died
waiting for our guest
we have a little bit of a
hiccup with the technical
we lost you there
hello
sorry okay we lost you there
okay so what i was asking was so
people are not going to go ahead and get
this from the mainstream media we got
you
really sharing some exposing many of the
things that are happening there uh thank
you again for being with us continue on
but tell us again for those that missed
it how many innocent people these are
innocent men and women men women and
children were actually what are the
conservative numbers of people that were
killed there on this
war
i would say
that we don't have the exact figures
because no calculation but you can say
last year 40 000 people died so
we we're talking about civilians and
everyone
so in general i would say about uh
800 to a million people have lost their
life and in this war on terror of
america 800 000 to a million those would
you say that's a pretty conservative
number
this is a number that i would calculate
based on the figures on the ground but
not a figure from the un because they
don't have proper figures but
if i calculate for example last in
2018 of 2020 2020 there were 40 000
people uh killed only the army members
of the previous government so imagine 40
000 only in the army so then you can
calculate that with civilians and the
police and other people i got a bunch of
more questions before we run out of time
have you ever and to add to these
numbers to give people kind of a visual
picture
you had this documentary i don't know if
you've ever seen it called dirty wars
and they show how people would be at a
wedding
and i mean again these are people just
imagine yourself say just imagine you
your like daughter's getting married and
next thing you know you've got foreign
troops coming in and they kill half of
your
family on a wedding night for example
right and these are actual things that
happen a drone attack
boom destroys a whole village a whole
town innocent people these are people
who are farmers people in the cave they
don't even have a tv
for crying out loud minding their own
business they don't care about you they
don't care about your way of life
they're just trying to live their way of
life and next thing you know they got a
bomb in their backyard
so these are the kind of things that
we're instigating creating you know
people to hate you
uh
so these are the kind of things that
it's important to bring to light so go
ahead continue on
this is a true story actually they
the americans have bombed
cities
hospitals
wedding
parties
graduation ceremonies
and when they were asked why you did
that sorry it was a mistake
you understand
sorry it was a mistake
and imagine when you kill somebody's
daughter
or son
father their loved one the hatred they
will have for you
but despite that
right now when taliban took over again
they are saying there's a general
honesty we have forgiven everyone
let's mine our own business and don't
get involved with us
even now americans are creating i mean
the western powers are creating
different problems
and if we have time we will discuss
about what's in the future for
afghanistan they are they will create
different problems for afghanistan but
hopefully i would say whatever they
happen in the past
if they kill people in afghanistan there
will be accountability of judgment no
doubt in that if the people on the
ground the militant group on the ground
kill
innocent people they will be accountable
day of judgment they will answer those
things
but right now what we can do is to ask
people before
they think about something else they
should educate themselves and do not
trust their politician because they fail
in iraq they fit in vietnam they fail in
afghanistan and they're filled other
countries as well do not trust them
again and question your politician that
why they have certain policy against
certain countries
this is a important point here you
mentioned the forgiveness now that they
are
choosing to forgive
now i don't think they're just doing
this off of their own whims and desires
because the natural way for the human
being they want revenge right
so from here and you can i mean you can
look at like you know how many innocent
people were killed and whatnot
but if you look at the example
would you connect it to
a unique part in history where you had
the prophet muhammad last the final
messenger sent to mankind after the
persecution of the muslims at that time
for how many years in the boycotts and
the you know killing of so many innocent
people when prophet muhammad came back
the victor in mecca with an army of what
10 000 strong
he ended up forgiving
the people
you think they're trying to follow this
example yeah hopefully uh hopefully this
we don't know i'm not i'm
they have given this example of uh the
prophet
they have and um yes they have given the
example but the prophet sallam he proved
it in action but so far the action has
to be actually being involved so i i
wouldn't take it very serious until it's
been proven in work action these are
just mere words
and of course muslims are inspired by
that and by the way the what's the
interesting part is what the taliban did
is they basically did the same thing
they took their biggest enemy and said
okay you know what
he will be our leader meaning that he
will be part of the government he will
be part of the group and just like
abu sufyan he consider his house like
his house is a safe house he he said to
khalid walid and everybody he gave them
a lot of respect and they are doing the
same thing but the difference is
he proved in action and taliban are
saying it and they have not done
anything wrong until now but i don't
know exactly because we have to wait and
give them time to prove that what they
have said is they're going to show it in
action as well or they just mere words
do you see someone also hypocrisy here
when you have you know places like
france you know oppressing women
and specif particularly the muslim women
you know who are trying to go ahead and
hear to the commands of god almighty the
creator you know their god-given rights
and now they're being oppressed and now
you have over here
nobody's really talking about that but
over here now everybody's worried about
the women of afghanistan like do you see
kind of like a hypocrisy
of course there's a hypocrisy and to the
level that we cannot describe it but
what if what's happening in france
people can't go to school and they can't
get education because they're wearing
certain certain types of clothes and
nobody's talking about that but what's
happening in afghanistan there's a
discussion and
this is a huge level of hypocrisy i
would say my two sisters are both
medical doctors and they're in
afghanistan so say that again hold on so
you have two sisters who live there and
they're both medical doctors yes yeah
you made it you made it you made a a
statement you said if women
if the women are uneducated the whole
family is uneducated powerful states
that's
yeah and that's how we look at it from
my family i mean every family
afghanistan who would not want their
children to eat education
but the thing is where people get this
kind of mixed up obviously i mean you
know
we want there's a first our priorities
is to get to know the purpose of life to
get to know our creator so that's like
the where people go off and they chase
everything else but that's and then you
can build off that obviously what do you
say about that
the point is that
when people are giving a certain way of
life
and they think that's the only way of
life is i mean would give us happiness
and when we look at their own life which
is miserable they don't have internal
happiness
and they don't know what's going to
happen to them what the purpose of their
life is
when we know at the same time
we want to get the best of this dunya in
as i was talking about my sisters
martial they are muslim
very proper hijab going to university
they're both medical doctors saving
lives
so now
if my sister would come to france they
would not become medical doctor because
of french government wow but nobody
would point out that these two girls are
not getting education because they want
to wear hijab you understand me yeah so
same problems yes in afghanistan we do
have problems i'm not denying it at all
we don't have proper facilities we're
not giving everything
but we are acknowledging our problems
and we don't mind if the western
countries acknowledge our problems too
and correct us
and help us to overcome those problems
if they can do that we'll be very happy
but they should do the same thing they
should point out the media should point
out what's happening in france
to the people of faith and what's
happening in afghanistan to the
industrial people they should point out
both but what they do they always talk
about afghanistan and what's negative
but they don't talk about their own
countries what's happening in their own
land and how they're treating the
muslims or women in general yeah what
place what society i mean there's
problems you know people are you know
homes are filled with problems countries
i feel the problem but that's what
you're you know alluding i mean pointing
out it's like people who now you have uh
your name your neighbors coming and
complaining about your son or daughter
and they're forgetting about you know
again it's one thing trying to come and
help and whatnot but now they're trying
to spot shine the spotlight on one of
your children they did something wrong
but over here their kid is involved in
you know all sorts of evil and
corruption bullying the whole school you
know on drugs and alcohol in the gang
he's a mafia guy carter you hey hold on
man you know it's like uh i think it was
was it jesus peace be upon him who we
love and revere is one of the mightiest
messengers talking about get that's you
know before you talk about someone's
else's speck in the air get that log out
of your eye
so you see a lot of that's the thing
that blatant hypocrisy you know and
thank god that many people all over the
world are starting to wake up and see
that
i think that's the reason they left
afghanistan because people are waking up
and look at california homeless problem
they don't talk about that but they want
to spend trillions of dollars in
afghanistan why why you cannot just
build them houses and let them know on
the street these are fundamental
questions people should ask what about
the student debts what's happening every
america is in the debt and he's dying in
debt and people are suffering because of
student debt and the credit problem in
the housing problem and you have every
source of problem every woman is working
two three jobs every man is working to
see each other and people are sleeping
on the street flipping is rough and
there is a medical condition look at the
medical facilities in america and the
insurance system people should look at
their own problems before they finger
somewhere else yes you can point out
their mistakes but acknowledge your own
as well
that what they do unfortunately and when
they go to afghanistan and other
countries you know the american media
what they do they do it like this
this is heaven this is heaven and this
is america and we are perfect nation so
therefore we should follow our way of
life and that's wrong because not
what what do you uh
have to uh can you comment on what
people are seeing the visual of like the
planes taking off and people falling off
the planes and that
yes so
there is a
panic attack yes there's a panic attack
with people who work with americans even
though taliban have announced it uh
general amnesty but again i've said it
just in words i haven't seen any action
meaning that we need some time to prove
if it's true or not
people do have panic attack and they're
because of civil war for example if i'm
in the government i've killed somebody
from taliban and now i'm afraid for
myself my son has done that i was for
example a police guy and i've done
something i was in charge of the prison
i was translated and
took the american to some people houses
to search them i showed them where to
drop a bomb so of course there's a fear
just like here in the uganda
people after you know that massacre
there was a fear and second thing is
now what they want to do by showing some
of the images in some of the you know
americans army holding babies there's
also former propaganda that we are
leaving therefore people are coming
after us
i would say
yes there is a fear i'm not denying that
there is a fear but
85 or 90 people they just want to leave
the country economical reasons
they want to come to germany or to us or
to uk for more economical reasons not
because of safety if any country you
give the same announcement
in mexico people will be dropping off
the plane
like without visa without plane ticket
everything is free i will give you the
document you can live here come you give
the same announcement to iran people
will do the same you give the same
announcement to any country who doesn't
want to travel and live in a different
country free of charge i would choose to
do that you understand me unless and of
course you have destroyed the country
you've destroyed the economy there was
everything was
fake you were dropping the money and
running the economy and you're gone of
course there's a uh people are scared
for themselves for the economy so and so
forth the second thing what they want to
do i believe
they want to take away the talents from
afghanistan
everyone who is there right now who who
was trained in afghanistan for example
the engineers the doctors and the
pharmacists the physicists a lot of
people they are literally pointing out
people who are with good education and
they're accepting their application
do you believe that so they can take out
the talent from afghanistan and leave
the next government with empty hands and
you cannot build a country by reciting
surah falafen sudinas and saying the
country can't be built they want to
create the next problem economically
they will say you know what we left look
at them now
so there are political reasons to it as
well
what do you think uh what do you foresee
now with your family being there you
know you being born there you have a lot
a lot of experience
you know with um
with things that are going on what do
you foresee in the future do you do you
see uh light at the end of the tunnel do
you see now change for the positive
uh taking place
yeah
i have noted six points
what's the future
generally speaking i'm very happy that
america left and i'm extremely happy
that they have left honestly because
with their presence nothing was in good
order and since they have left now it's
up to us
to rebuild that country and inshallah
make it a good example of a muslim
leadership it made a good example of a
place where everybody is welcome muslim
non-muslim and they can come live in
peace i i think we are definitely
capable of that and we can shall do it
for the future afghanistan hopefully the
taliban form an inclusive government of
everyone if it's from every tribe tajik
hazara uzbek pashtun everybody is in
well it will be the best thing to do if
not the taliban will overtake in or the
new government might come in power in
next five or ten years because if there
is no peace people should see themselves
in the government if people should see
part of the progress and part of the
change if they don't see it like of
course they will be against it the
second thing is if we can bring people
closer to each other and you know make
them to work out with each other because
it's very difficult after four days of
war and killing in destruction people
there will be psychological problem with
people i hope if they can come together
and forget what happened in the past and
focus in the future it is a difficult
job to do because uganda is still
suffering and they are still struggling
with those things but hopefully they can
overcome this challenge and come
together because honestly speaking last
week
my own nephew who was born my sister
were looking forward to have a son for
10 years he was born and my sister was
extremely happy to a degree that
whenever he would sleep my sister would
come up because he slept for too long i
hope nothing happens to him you know he
was she was scared if you sleep for too
long she was scared if something would
happen to him and that little child for
one and a half month old he was killed
in the crossfire between the taliban and
the government so imagine my own angles
my relatives have been killed it's very
difficult to forgive and move on but we
as a muslim have to do that because we
believe in the reward from
the third challenge that the future
afghanistan is holding is basically
economical challenges the previous
economy was created virtually in a fake
economy by the americans flooding their
money channeling back to there is no
actual gdp or actual growth or domestic
products and services so it's a huge
challenge for the people to create the
economy but it's okay if we challenge
the economy as long as we have the peace
the fourth as i mentioned earlier
the western countries they are taking
away talent from amazon engineers web
developers software developers they are
taking them away it will be a great
challenge for us to find uh tenants in
afghanistan right now i would like i
wanted to hire three people for one of
my startup and for the organization it's
very difficult to find people who
actually know the work because the most
of the talent is gone from the country
and they're living now and the western
countries paying their taxes and working
because if a child is born in for
example in germany the government
spending one
i think 200 000 euros until he become
the age of 20 or something to pay back
the taxes so imagine you can get
somebody from afghanistan from third
world country third world countries to
not spend you don't have any investment
you can he can come back to the country
and fulfill the jobs and pay taxes it's
a win situation for these countries they
don't have to invest on the child
actually so that's that's a great
challenge for advanced talent and
education again i said in my previous
interviews as well that real education
we have only 20 people who are really
really educated and they have left most
of them afghanistan they have left it
would be a great challenge to form a new
education system and to educate people
at least to take maybe 20
20 30 years and again the sixth problem
is that the afghanistan is facing is a
secular muslims i hope that the taliban
continue leading the way of the process
and getting the example from there just
like he was leading a leadership
and madina but he also had
in makkah so if we can bring both period
together the period of madinah and the
period of makkah there should be thou
are going on there should be education
people should be regularly educated
about islam and islamic leadership at
the same time there should be firm
leadership upon justice and upon haqq
and upon the islamic principles if they
can follow these three principles
of justice harmony and peace with giving
quality of life to people and hopefully
this country will flourish it will be a
great example of muslims and islam in
the whole world inshallah
what are your before we conclude
you've uh this is not some thing that is
um made up it's a fact that there was
over half a billion dollars spent by the
pentagon to go ahead and create
fake terrorist videos
lies you know this um
negative propaganda so anybody can look
this up this is just fact it's it came
out so now contrast that with
if the leadership there
if they put aside
a good amount of money for positive pr
for truthful pr public relations
that now they got to go ahead
and send out you know the the
you know uh basic things of establishing
justice you know eradicating trying to
eradicate poverty all the things that
islam calls for
you know to get rid of this nationalism
to call people to the pure monotheism to
let people see the quran in action
because right now there's such a
negative they just see people as
backwards they just see these people who
can't speak you know you can't
communicate all they have is guns with
them so what do you think about that you
know having the proper pr and the pr of
truth of getting the truth out
it will be extremely easy to spread the
truth then just convince people with
falsehood the convincing people
falsehood require huge amount of budget
just like american government you
mentioned spend half a billion dollars
on it uh how much 500 billion or 500
million uh 500 million so half a billion
half a billion
that yeah people can google this and
look this up just yes
inside the country subhanallah
i would say once the government is
formed there are early stages and i'm
going to make this clear i will never be
joining any government if it's an
afghanistan this one or previous one
whatsoever i will always work
independently as a humanitarian workers
other entrepreneur and islamic guy i
will work independently that's people
should say clear because it's important
to make it clear once the government is
formed and everything is okay i think
what they can do is it to invite
the the on influencers that's the
influence of the economy and the world
of influence if they can invite them so
they themselves can see the country can
see the justice and then they can share
with other people i think that would be
a great pr for people to understand what
uh islamic values and
muslims are yeah just like jason who is
a former um who's a marine i shared that
story came over there got to experience
the kindness the hospitality of the
muslims there and then he was given a
copy of the quran he read the quran with
open heart and open mind and now he
wants to accept islam submission to the
creator not the creation the way of
jesus moses and the last the fellow
master prophet muhammed peace and
blessing be upon them all thank you very
much
i just want to point out this actually i
wanted to invest in the area if i can
build a place in afghanistan in nuristan
and and white people from outside of the
afghanistan like non-muslims and they
can come
for example the the living cost will be
free for them they can live there and
experience the country experience the
muslims learn about islam right
i was actually i was planning to do
something like that so they can see the
muslims that they can learn about the
religion they can see the country in
islam in practice and then they can go
back to their home countries and make
their own choice inshallah but you
should not look at islam just for the
worldly reason you should look it for
the most salvation reason that what will
happen to you after that what is the
reason of your life and why you were
created and who created you and these
are more important questions to answer
hopefully we can create the experience
for them
so this is what you're talking you're
thinking about doing are you going to do
you're going to make like a a project
where you can invite the not yet muslims
people to come you know to experience
afghanistan people like to travel they
can learn a little bit about the culture
learn about islam and get to see from
themselves make the human connection
yes that's the plan inshallah inshallah
so where could people if they want to go
ahead and follow you to go ahead and
keep up with hopefully if this project
comes to fruition
i think the best would be since i was
actually
making i was on youtube but then for
three years i left it now i'm trying to
come back to youtube to explain more
about muslim entrepreneurship and how
they muslims can you know be good at
both in dunya and so they can definitely
check out the youtube channel and then
this project will be announced queries
beautiful they can put your name in here
thank you very much for giving us some
history some on the ground what's
happening and enlightening us and
exposing us to what we're not really
getting from the mainstream media
thank you very much
thank you